and last week I don't know if you saw
this in social media it was old
headshot day and it was actors would
we're posting their kind of first ed
shot now did any of you join in or am I
just going to bully you into doing it
now you've got a bully okay Stephen
Mangan I have to say Stephen you you sir
have aged very very well
that's not what's terrifying about that
is not only at some point in my life so
look at that and go yeah but also when
you get a professional picture taken as
you'll know they give you about 60 to
choose from and I chose that work when
you look like that no not even it's a
course they're never gonna see it so
many mysteries on the Magic Roundabout
[Laughter]
this is your very very very very first
publicity shot this is the one you
Wow but you do put out of business cards
didn't you yes I did the business well I
was trying to keep my options open
sonica good fly suck yeah I lived in a
bedsit I'm a landlord I feel I could
pose in front of his Mustang or whatever
American card it was different from the
straightforward you know pen to business
card I put the service station on the
machine yeah
and of course Emilia vlogs will be
looked high and low for an early
headshot of you and and we did
eventually found one on this way no have
we bosses no we didn't buy it no it's
not free it's $1.99 seriously this one
even wanted $1.99 finally in the
interest of full disclosure vas got this
is my first this is my spot you know the
spot like that if the directory of
actors so what's weird about this is it
looks like it was a hundred years ago
that I looked like this but it wasn't
that long ago that I've just [ __ ]
myself up
funny hair but you look kind of the same
you know what you were slightly older
than that when I went to Argos and using
the safety training video the boxes
[Applause]
[Music]
tumble no no because I didn't have to be
dead yes where's your corpse in Argos
boxes under cater for every gift idea
they use a real ambulance in the thing
and we were told we needs to be quick
because if a call comes in that
ambulance has to go
[Music]
you